the point of order with your permission
Mr Speaker I said never before in all
our centuries of our parliamentary
democracy has the house listened to such
an address in a great European Capital
now within range of Russian guns
President Vladimir zielinski is standing
firm for democracy and for freedom in
his righteous defense I believe he has
moved the hearts of everybody in this
house at this moment ordinary ukrainians
are defending their homes and their
families against a brutal assault and
they are by their actions inspiring
Millions by their courage and their
devotion and I think today one of the
proudest boasts in the Free World is yah
Ukraine it I am a Ukrainian so this is a
moment for us to put our political
differences aside Mr Speaker and I know
I speak for the whole house when I say
the Britain and our allies are
determined to press on
to press on with supplying our Ukrainian
friends with the weapons they need to
defend their Homeland as they deserve to
press on with tightening the economic
Vice around Vladimir Putin and we will
stop importing Russian oil Mr Speaker my
right honorable friend the business
secretary will update the house on that
tomorrow and we will employ every method
that we can diplomatic humanitarian and
economic Mr Speaker until Vladimir Putin
has failed in this disastrous Venture
and Ukraine is free once more